bonjour fabrice di vizio merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
alors se séduire de la santé comment
d'ailleurs les professionnels de santé
que vous défendez accueille cette
initiative gouvernementale comme une
mascarade
cette initiative c'est une mascarade
politique et rien d'autre qui peut
penser raisonnablement qu'on peut
réformer un système de santé urgemment
vite la maintenant en pleine sortie à
peine de crise sanitaire entre juin
finalement fin mai et le tout en sept
semaines
donc le système de santé français ne
mérite pas qu'on s'y penche plus de
cette semaine c'est ça que ça veut dire
d'une barre d'autre part si c'était
aussi simple
bon bah alors pourquoi est ce qu'on ne
l'a pas fait avant donc de deux choses
l'une soit la question est complexe soit
effectivement la question est simple et
on peut se demander pourquoi on n'a pas
réglé avant donc n'attendons rien de ce
secteur de la santé de l'argent va être
distribué ces des cadeaux voilà j'ai vu
sur une de vos affiches dans le
reportage de l'argent gratuit voilà de
l'argent magique pour l'hôpital public
c'est tout ce qu'on veut de l'argent
magique voilà si la france on veut de
l'argent magique en france on résout les
problèmes par un saupoudrage financier
qui ne va rien résoudre alors vous dites
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne l'a pas fait
maintenant parler aussi des du délai
requis vous semble plutôt court 1 d'ici
juillet pour trouver des solutions
pourtant il faut bien commencer par
quelque chose
favoriser la division il faut surtout
commencer par se poser la question de
savoir pourquoi l'allemagne et la france
finalement investissant à peu près
autant en part de pib dans la santé l'un
s'en sort mieux et pas l'autre et je
vous dis tout de suite si je si on
regarde le constat ça va pas nous plaire
parce que l'un des constats c'est qu'en
allemagne nous sommes dans un système
par exemple d'assurance-maladie
concurrentiel
avons effectivement une part de
privatisation des hôpitaux qui a bien
fonctionné et ça est ce que les
syndicats l'hospitalier français sont
prêts à l'entendre
absolument pas parce qu'en france on
considère que la santé est si l'hôpital
public d'ailleurs vous noté de façon
intéressante qu'elle soit ou les
infirmières libérales
ils sont où les kinés de ville ils sont
où les orthophonistes où sont
effectivement les médecins de ville
tous ces gens est-ce qu'il participe au
secteur de la santé
ben pas tellement finalement on entend
on va réformer l'hôpital public et dans
la crise du coc vide c'est intéressant
l'hôpital public il a pris combien
commis à quel pourcentage tutelle
publique at il pris en charge de
patients allaient 20% mais 80% des
patients ont été pris en charge en ville
les premiers effectivement avoir été
concernées par la clau vide c'est les
médecins de ville les premiers acteurs
du système de santé c'est les médecins
de ville les premiers acteurs c'est les
infirmiers et kinés de ville
mais finalement eu banon bayeux on va
pas les saupoudrer d'argent parce que ça
fonctionne pas comme ça donc si vous
voulez moi je suis un vieux chez un
vieux baroudeur je connais le système de
santé français est ce que je sais c'est
que là c'est de la démagogie pure on va
arroser un peu d'argent on va trouve à
saupoudrer mais on va rien régler et la
prochaine crise on se reprendra en
pleine figure c'est tout alors les
revendications prioritaires mise en
avant par le gouvernement va voir ça
cette après midi
cela concerne la hausse des salaires des
personnels soignants leurs conditions de
travail
mais ce que vous dites c'est que ce qui
compte finalement c'est de revoir le
budget alloué aux au système de santé en
france
ce que je dis c'est que au titre des
revendications y en a qui sont
évidemment légitime qu'est celle de
l'augmentation des salaires ça paraît
évident quand vous voyez combien est
payé un infirmier ça paraît évident mais
attention hein parce que lapin
finalement des infirmiers la part de
salaire des infirmiers en termes de
revenus moyens elle est légèrement
inférieure à ce qui se passe ailleurs
mais pas tant que ça donc croire on va
régler le problème de leur recrutement
d'infirmiers par un salaire je pense que
c'est un peu illusoire ce que les
soignants réclame d'abord c'est une
amélioration des conditions de travail
ça c'est certain mais surtout
effectivement une considération de leurs
fonctions et aujourd'hui ce que je crois
vraiment c'est que l'hôpital doit être
débarrassée de toute la technocratie ça
c'est une évidence et vous regardez
un truc extrêmement intéressant comme
disent mes clients qui ont été chefs de
service aux urgences c'est qu'en fait
l'administration à ce chip pour payer
des fonctionnaires pour apprendre chef
de service à se passer le médecin c'est
à dire que en fait plutôt que de
recruter des médecins recrute des
fonctionnaires pour leur apprendre à
s'en passer
c'est tout à fait extraordinaire bien
mais on ne fera pas si vous voulez le
grand soir de la santé ceux qui
attendent un grand soir de la santé vont
être pour leur compte bien sur que non
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
aujourd'hui c'est gouvernement cherche à
calmer une grogne sociale
au demeurant légitime en saupoudrant
l'exploit niant vont avoir quelques
gages avec quelques quelque argent et
quelques promesses
ça va calmer la colère pendant quelque
temps mais vous verrez qu'à la première
grippe saisonnière devraient même une
grippe saisonnière
une première pandémie de grippe le
système va exploser alors vous voulez
dire vous représentez le collectif ces
19 collectif de médecins vous avez porté
plusieurs plaintes un olivier ferrand il
voir philippe agnès buzyn sont visés là
il n'est pas question de lâcher ou
est-ce que vous en êtes au niveau
judiciaire
bon ben nous on en est si vous voulez au
stade où on a déposé des plaintes devant
la cour de shiso république d'un côté
dans le parquet de paris de l'autre
elles sont actuellement en cours d'étude
par la commission des requêtes
il va de soi que bien sûr nous ne
lâcherons rien dès lors que l'objectif
étant non pas d'avoir des coupables mais
la vérité que nous voulons la vérité sur
ce que savait ce gouvernement et quels
sont les propos d'un guebuza comme agnès
buzyn peut-elle dire qu'elle savait tout
mais n'a rien fait comment est il
possible que monsieur veron ne nous est
pas transmis les bons de commande des
fameux masque donc voilà nous ce que
nous souhaitons c'est savoir ce qui
s'est réellement passé
et est ce que oui ou non il y a eu d
abstention volontaire
les premières choses que l'on doit aux
soignants avant un peu d'argent je
voulais guy où on a vraiment
l'impression quand même la donne est
dans une situation de simon terrible où
on se transforme finalement en
organisation caritative à qui on
distribue de l'argent non ce que veulent
les soignants c'est de la considération
et cette considération elle passe par la
vérité
il y a
des manquements graves dans cette crise
du coc vide il m'a dit mme buzyn à jeter
de l'huile sur le feu en disant qu' elle
savait tout mais n'a rien fait monsieur
vers en a rajouté un peu d'huile en ne
produisant pas les bons de commande
donc à partir de là avant de commencer à
donner de l'argent comment sont pas
manifestés le respect en donnant la
vérité que monsieur virant produisent
les bons de commande
si monsieur vers ambre est à ce point
soucieux des soignants et bien qu'ils
produisent les banques comment ça
pourrait être ça la première
revendication qu'ils produisent les
fameux bon de commande pour savoir à
quelle date il a commandé les masques
parce que s'il ne les a pas commandé et
qu'il a menti à la france entière
bah alors toutes ces négociations elle
ne sert absolument à rien merci beaucoup
fabrice di vizio je rappelle que vous
êtes avocat de professionnels de santé
merci à vos fins